we're gonna I'll stand aside and he can
stand beside the video since you'll be
talking during the video great all right
well good afternoon everyone I'm nan
Whaley mayor of the Dayton have a lot of
folks from the police department here
but I'm here with chief Beall City Mayor
Shelly Dickstein and city commissioner
matt joseph gosh it's been a few days
since we've had an update this weekend
we're really pleased with just the
outpouring of support we've received
from the community you know I've
attended tickets yeah six six
visitations or funerals the families I
think we're very pleased to see the
number of people that came and supported
them and they're going through a very
difficult time obviously now and really
just asking people to continue to keep
them in their in your prayers and
thoughts as they're moving through this
incredible grief and the Dayton fund
foundation is continuing to see strong
support and appreciate the support that
regular folks and businesses and pretty
much everybody of all stripes coming
together to that fund which i think is
not surprising to me considering how how
cohesive this community is we're super
pleased Sunday John Legend came with
every town survivor Network to really
have a great event with people that have
survived the shooting and quite a few of
them were at blind Bob's to see a really
powerful performance and I think that
that was therapeutic frankly for some
their Sunday and so we were grateful
that we were able to help out there too
and we'll continue to think of ways that
we can be helpful both to the district
to the survivors into the community at
large at the same time while pushing
forward common excuse me common sense
gun control legislation we have a couple
of updates for you first we're gonna
have city manager Shelly Dean talk about
just the totality of the organization
and what the this organization has done
during this
this this tragic event and then chief
Beale is going to give an overall
timeline of exactly what happened that
evening so I will turn it over to
Shelley Thank You mayor so I know
there's been a lot of attention given to
the officers that we actually engaged in
the shooting are taking neutralizing the
shooter I did want to be able to provide
a summary of all of the work this
organized organization did it is there
was a lot of heroic service provided
across the organization and across the
region so just to sum up a few things to
help you understand her to highlight the
total response we had helping the police
department there were 14 responding
agencies from federal state county and
other local jurisdictions the actions a
lot of the actions included of course
engaging the shooter but applying first
aid performing CPR applying tourniquets
comforting victims securing the crime
scene collecting physical and digital
evidence some of which the chief will
walk through today ongoing investigation
alack tivities managing the message
regarding the event and the
investigation to the media and general
public and supporting their teammates
through this very difficult time the
fire department was the first department
to create the command post to integrate
police and fire into a unified command
they responded our Dayton Fire
Department responded with a medic units
six engines three letters and a lot of
other specialized units to support the
response to the event
Dayton Fire Department had seven
jurisdictions that sent twelve
additional medics five jurisdictions
provided fire station fill in and
responded to a working structure fire on
McClain Street
they also spent time supporting and
continue to spend time supporting their
teammates through this event and beyond
recreation youth services provided
facility support at the Dayton
Convention Center for the emergency
operation center and communications
center they also provided space and
coordinated with a Red Cross to create
the Family Assistance Center and they
coordinated the press room where we did
multiple multiple press events the
Department of Public Works provided a
variety of Street maintenance activities
and help set up the stage for the Sunday
night vigil the office of public affairs
city manager's office Mary Commission
office and the law department
established and promoted clear channels
for residents and media to get accurate
and timely info including live-streaming
press events and pushing out info on
city social media channels and website
they own they also coordinated an
enormous amount of media calls and
ensured local and national media had
access to city leaders and finally
managed a great deal of donations and
outpouring of public support and pushed
out information to to start the
community and the healing process so
aside from the police officers who
engaged in the shooting there were
literally hundreds of people within our
organization and throughout the region
who provided heroic service to address
this tragic event well good afternoon we
will provide an update on a couple of
things here today first to give a little
bit an update as you might understand
that after an event of this magnitude
that preliminary information on
casualties is preliminary and so we
actually had people who were walk ons or
walk into hospitals asked me for
services subsequent to that day
so the total here is listed before you I
won't read that out in terms of
fatalities as well as also non-fatal
these are gunshot wounds so this is
everyone killed or injured through a
gunshot wound in total of 26 victims 15
female and 11 male and you can see the
racial demographic breakdown of all of
those victims we thought it was
important to give you it updates as
complete as we can at this time although
I don't anticipate any additional
victims necessarily coming forth we need
to be still open to that possibility I
will say that there has been incredible
interest by probably all media agencies
on something called timeline and I was
asked a number of questions in really
middle last week about can I confirm
this video coverage of the individual
with inside of blind box and I you know
the fact that these folks were together
all three the assailant his sister and
his companion and I made it very clear
at that time that's relevant in terms of
a point in time but that's not really
our biggest concern our concern was once
they separated then what happened and
what was that time frame we now fill
that in so you see right now the we are
able to confirm the arrival of those
three individuals in a vehicle that was
parked behind in the tie nine parking
lots you know where that's at I assume
most of you and that was 1104 because
there was a parking ticket that had that
time stamped on it able to confirm the
time of arrival we know immediately upon
arrival all three headed to a blind box
and remain there until 1213 a.m. when
the assailant in fact left
one across the street to Ned peppers
where he remained until 1242 a.m. he
then goes back to the parking lot and
then spins back to tonight where the
vehicles had and he spends the next
eight minutes gathering a content out of
the trunk of that vehicle in which he
has also now changed a tire he has a
very heavy backpack that he is carrying
he then goes to the rear of a high
Newcomb's and the heart mercantile
location and he is there for about nine
minutes and it's at that point there's
physical evidence not only their video
evidence there's physical evidence to
confirm that he was at that location and
maybe that detail in this presentation
and then at the 104 a.m. he emerges
behind the alley and that's one the
shooting begins so this slide here is
obviously an overhead view of the Oregon
district where this incident occurred
covering all the way from the if you
look in the bottom left corner of this
TV screen that's the tie nine parking
lot so that's where the vehicle is
parked and now we'll show you the path
that all through all three took from
that vehicle two blind Bob says this
green line that shows their path of
travel all of this will be validated
subsequently through video and I'm going
to ask lieutenant Paul Saunders who is a
commander of strategic planning Bureau
who had a team six people working on
reviewing 250 gigabytes of video to try
to determine path of travel if we
identify the suspect and the assailant
his path of travel and timeframes the
next
blue line is when the assailant leaves
blind Bob's goes across the street to
Ned peppers where he's there for roughly
a half an hour and then goes east on
history down Jackson Street and then
West back through the alley where he had
originally come the first time but then
turned to go up toward blind Bob's when
he was at that particular walkway the
next is his path of travel once he has
obtained the wound REE the backpack his
vest this hoodie he put on so this shows
his path the travel from the parking lot
back to the walkway right adjacent to
blind Bob's where the shooting begins
and where three individuals were fatally
wounded then across the street there's
additional victims along the north side
of Fifth Street adjacent to a nearby
peppers and there's another victim on
the south side of the street in front of
tumbleweed
correct Emily this now shows this is the
video that was obtained from multiple
businesses I won't try to name them all
but these are the video recorded video
that was obtained and documented this
time frame these paths of travel and the
activity most particularly when the
assailant left the company of his sister
and his companion so I will now have
lieutenant Paul Saunders come up to the
podium and he will walk you through the
video some of which we may have to show
more than once I will warn you in
advance some of the video is is rather
grainy some has really good clarity so
the the way were able to say this is
that this is the assailant is based on
line of other video and other data
points so we're absolutely confident
even though the image seems to be
indistinguishable who that is that we
are confident that this in fact the
assailant who was being tracked by video
throughout this gap in time from the
time he left his sister in his companion
and began shooting afterwards when you
get a chance to see this and if you need
to kind of rewind and see the video
again again if it's hard for you to it's
harder for three I watched it a lot of
times sometimes it hard for me to
actually see the movement and individual
on the video so if we need to do rewind
we'll do it we will make this publicly
available so you will have it so no
further ado lieutenant Saunders I'll
bring you up so a couple before we get
going on housekeeping when you see the
video and it's on the small TV because
of the quality we have different sources
of video from the surveillance cameras
to get the best quality possible we
decided to go on a smaller screen for
you because it gets real grainy if we
get on to a big screen the timestamps on
the individual videos are everybody had
their own timestamp on their on their
security videos so the with the
resources we had available we've had to
sync them as best we could so the times
at the top of this of the slides or what
we're going by we've highlighted in
yellow the different go back one more
Matt sorry the different viewpoints that
we have the lower left right here is a
residence that highlights the tylium
parking lot this is the record store
video highlights the time in parking lot
this that's a great clear video you're
gonna see that that's one of our
reference points you'll understand when
I'll talk about when we see so many
video that's very brainy blind so this
first video is at the time on parking
lot this is a private residence the
highlighted yellow is where is a tree
branch but it's actually behind that
tree branches everything where the
vehicle is and you'll see the three
people that's going to be the shooter
its sister and friend they're walking so
that they're walking east I'm sorry
eastbound right now on the right hand
side chrétien slides as a thumbnail that
shows the video that you're looking at
the camera viewpoint and it will show
the path so the next slide is going to
be behind the see that this shows the
three them together please note the
individual on the left is the shooter he
was wearing a shirt for most of the
evening that has that very distinctive
detail in the back that made it possible
for us to identify him in several
different video sources this is going to
be a short clip of a video of inside
blind Bob's they're gonna see the
shooter enter from the patio the sister
and printer still on the patio he's
gonna speak with the doorman for a
minute he's going to exit the time that
we have on this is about 13 minutes
after midnight he leaves here in just a
moment you getting clip next
and now he at 12:14 so a minute later
this is the shooter Henry Ned peppers he
goes into bed but Ned peppers he's there
for about thirty minutes
Ned peppers was very crowded shoulders
shoulder and then he leaves at 12:42
that's the key time off so remember the
1242 times we're getting closer to the
point of when these shooting again so
the shooter exits and we catch him on
video going eastbound on Fifth Street
you can see the firefighters in yellow
right up here you can see that shirt
that helps us find him he travels
eastbound you see the patch on the right
hand side and then moves on I'm sorry
back up one I apologize another point to
note so he has just come out of Ned
peppers this is a video from actually
hole in the wall which is Right adjacent
to Ned peppers the front of this is the
police cruiser this is where the police
are are they're very visible at this
point so the shooter actually comes out
of that peppers and walks right behind
that police cruisers aware of where they
were haven't seen them next slide
so this doesn't look like much but it is
a shirt you can see here this is him in
the alley
this is video that was caught from the
rear of this would-be tumbleweed
we know the 10 because of the timing
you'll see in the next couple slides
where it's very clearly in this is you
know next door this is from Hart
mercantile still in the alley the
shooter is not walking to the alley very
sees raining he's walking eastbound he's
walking back towards the car at this
point
and then this is behind you comes very
clear video when he comes across and
still walking eastbound you don't know
then he's still wearing a t-shirt he's
still in shorts there's no backpack it's
12:45 right now we know that at this
point he's heading back to the car we
catching in the alley this is from the
record store on Fifth Street you're
gonna see him coming from the left to
the right so then we're gonna switch
over to the private residence of camera
this is one you saw in the very
beginning he's behind the car if you
were on a high-resolution screen you can
see through this branch there's movement
it appears he's walking around the car
it appears that the trumpet's coming
open and shot he's there for about eight
minutes and the key thing here is he's
no longer wearing a short-sleeved
t-shirt and now we're in a
and here he comes accident so he's now
he's wearing the backpack wearing a long
sleeved shirt the path on the right hand
side shows how he went he's going to cut
back over to the alley this is from the
record store so we can catch him cutting
that same path right here and part of
this was just verifying at this point
that he had no interactions anybody else
here economics he's coming out the
building so this is the video behind
Newcomb's he's gonna come from screen
rights because now he's traveling east
now and you'll see that he has the
backpack and he's in long sleeves in the
backpack is weighted down it's not empty
so this is a key point here because
positive or a second man on the
thumbnail you'll see that this camera
view goes to the corner which is this
point of disability at this point we've
asked him for about nine minutes we
couldn't find him anywhere on the
following video go to the next screen so
this is a viewpoint from Park mercantile
which to pick up you'll notice right
here the opposite corner of that
building and we and you saw when he
walked we saw the image of him walking
across the first time you never could
seen coming this way
the guys finally picked it up watch
where we've highlighted the screen here
we'll probably have to play this portion
twice but when you play they're gonna
see him dart around the corner
you couldn't see it but he shoots around
that corner pretty quickly he was behind
the building behind him we have a pretty
good idea what he was doing there
because as he shoots up in this alley he
comes up this alley you know that he was
probably charging his weapon load and
unload the weapon up because the next
day as we're processing seeing
approximately where that highlighted
stories or where this placard is there
is an unspent round it's damaged like it
had to be ejected because he didn't
charge properly
Saddam's recovery was one a matching
what the shooter had so well pretty sure
that he was turning this corner he was
probably charging his weapon he had to
probably recharge it and the next video
is going to show the reason why we think
that I think the travelling up this
alley is when he began shooting so this
is another one we're gonna have to show
twice and I'll tell you what matters
second because the first thing you're
going to notice is the people that's
going to tell you when you actually have
rounds coming down range then we're
going to replay I want you to follow the
line of you superimpose and that'll show
when the shooter comes through here it's
hard to keep track both up but you're
going to notice after you see when they
start moving that the shooter doesn't
actually enter the frame and shock that
happens so this is the patio for buying
Bob's going around
now the movie they just heard shots and
after we played them for me it's going
to play it again and now that you've
seen when they start moving the best
place to seem is right here
the hill run this path
so there he goes and we know that he's
been firing been popular second because
just past this umbrella is the taco
stand on this street that's where our
first three fatalities occur one of them
is sister so we also know from homicide
Feldman from me
eyewitness accounts that as these
crosses this Creek which is right here
on the red line he continues to fire
down this street and there's evidence of
that that they collect it also good the
next life for me
so this slide you're looking at right
now is we're going to kind of move you
geographically down the street this is
from the hole in the wall
which is the store that is adjacent to
Ned peppers the cruiser I showed you
earlier it's actually it's not in the
picture right here but it's it's pending
this crowd but the cruiser and the
police will be right here this is a
crowd in front of the whole mall there
when the video starts they are reacting
shots fired and you're going to see the
first response of the officers and they
play clean so they've obviously just
heard the gunfire the first officer
coming around this corner you can see
will be option Vulcans to believe
followed by I believe officer generally
here the remainder of them will come out
will fan out right here and you can see
when this mic stutter on because this
video that is but I didn't this time so
they're engaging right now so this is
the the officers and because later on
you can barely see these guys from the
shot that we have and I wanted to start
off cuz that's the first response so the
next slide is now from Ned peppers and
this is now angling to the west so the
shooter is up the street he's crossed
55th Street he's been shooting down
range or down this street the officers
are reacting you saw officer Rolf Asst
you're gonna see him again he's gonna
come up in this portion of the screen we
have had to be back some of this just
because there's some sensitive material
on there that we didn't think was good
for the public but you're gonna get a
pretty good idea
half of the shooter and the first
response of the officers didn't see us
what was ten come up here and you'll see
on the right-hand side the path of all
savolta's approximately so he's engaging
right now that was a shooter we just
went behind so officer role came up and
then he is now just responded back one
play again so there's officer role
physicians right in the middle there
there's the shooter coming by so he was
engaged there so we're gonna go to the
next slide which is still going to be
from this is from Ned peppers this will
be the end of this scene so the first
slide of officers I showed you was the
officers all fanning out so they're all
up here
so next door is hole in the wall this is
Ned peppers front door you just saw down
here officer office engaging the shooter
as he was running on the sidewalk so
you're going to see the shooter continue
to run right here and it's going to end
right here
Daniel played for me
so if you look on the right you can see
the sugars that the blue dots by our
best resources that we have at our
fingertips we believe that the shooting
started at approximately 105 and 35
seconds we believe it ended at 106 and
seven seconds that's 32 seconds which
video looking at our first engagement
was about halfway through that the all
of this data has been turned over for
more technical analysis with the FBI
that'll take quite a bit I mean it took
us a while to go through what we've got
and we were just honing in on certain
parts they will be going through audio
and syncing social media which we
collected that also but in a nutshell
this accounts for the shooters movements
from the time he arrived in the or
district to the a 23 I'm sorry 1104
would be the first 1104 1105 that would
be in the Oregon District parking lot
when their very first clip I showed you
him exiting the vehicle the time on the
20 exid's Ned peppers yes there's well
the police vehicle and likely police
officers at the same time yeah that's a
great question I think there's a I think
there's a good whether he had gone into
Ned peppers the case that I I think
that's a there's a strong probability
but let me also say that he was he was
very familiar with the oregon district
so this was not a place that he did not
know
no there's no indication that he had me
had contact with individual in there but
there's no indication any of those ropes
of significance that would generate some
kind of response like this I mean this
this was a plan well before he got to
the organ district well I think it was
really important you know were their
co-conspirators were there's some other
folks aiding and abetting we're not
saying that's this is the finality of
that conversation but clearly that day
during that timeframe we don't see
anyone assisting him in committing this
horrendous crime so that's important
information it also that plus some
follow-up investigation seems to
strongly suggest that his companion had
no idea what he was going to do nor did
he have any knowledge of the weapons
that were in the trunk of that vehicle
yeah he did know where they were at
because they were communicating during
this hour back and forth one brief phone
call we don't know content of that that
was his sister and he so don't know what
that content is but also text messages
also know there was there was no
invitation than meet there was a
communication that from his companion
that they were quote going to the taco
stand and that was about about seven
minutes or so before the shooting
occurred
you know it's an interesting question
and I will tell you that a lot of us
have been involved in this dialogue is
you know we all have been reviewing this
evidence including the homicide
detectives who were deeply immersed in
this we have radically different views
in that regard Nate if he we can't agree
and the interpretation of the evidence
where some are saying absolutely not he
was not intentional so I'm saying no it
had to be I would say it's inconclusive
well was the question whether the sister
was an intentional victim and his
companion he was also shot to survive
and I said basically the evidence has
been debated in both directions with
individuals in our organization
intimately familiar with the evidence
arguing both directions and if we base
on what we know now which is the key key
factor here if we can't seem to make
that call conclusively that we're
divided about how whether that was
intentional or not I think it's
inconclusive we may get a better insight
through historical data looking back but
based on the evidence from that night I
don't think we can make the call
none that I'm aware of I'm party boys
actually what you the officer was on
screen on this like the other video you
saw the officer is off screen was on
screen the shooter would have been off
screen initially come down the sidewalk
and there's more video out there by the
way so we're you know it's a great
question too I would say that the body
armor because of the way it was worn was
was vulnerable and fortunately we were
able to take advantage of that
vulnerability had plates but that's all
ballistic plates
you know that's something that the
coroner reviews in his examination he's
not complete and when he's ready to
discuss you know that particular what
the injuries were and caused those
injuries then you can have that
information we knows well we certainly
know three individuals we were shot
immediately right around blind Bob's so
they were the initial victims what is a
little bit anything uncertain for me out
of our detectives no I mean we had
someone completely on the the south side
of the street in front of tumbleweed and
everyone else is clustered on the other
side of street so when that shot was
fired that's not really clear for me at
this point although she was mobile so
she was shot and ran quite away so we're
still piecing that together
you know we've interviewed a lot of
folks I can't tell you who all we have
spoken to or if that person what the
content was I mean that's a level of
detail we're not going to go to provide
yeah I've kind of tried to create a
distinction here between motivation and
mindset I think it's an important
distinction to make motivation seems to
suggest this specific location this
particular night these individuals who
were victims I think that's way way way
downstream that's not the level of
clarity we all have now we certainly
don't have it now and whether we ever
have that is going to be you know
questioned mindset oh I think we have a
lot of information about mindset
historical data about mindset and its
progression but I want to remind you
that that is the principal focus right
now of the investigation by the Federal
Bureau of Investigation so they're
running with that we need them to run
with that you know that's what they do
best amongst other things by the way but
that is really their role and we're
gonna allow them to do that I don't
think more than I already am fied is
there is this his history of obsession
with violence and violence ideations the
discussion of interests in mass
shootings and expression of desire to
carry out a mass shooting I think that
should be enough theme Attica Lee that
you should get a pretty clear picture of
what was going on here
I'm not aware of it I mean that that
would been an interview about how much I
detectives and I don't have that level
of detail we really wanted to keep this
and I realize you have a lot of
questions we'll try it obviously trying
to fill in what gaps we can but I will
tell you that this this was the next big
I think chunk of the investigation that
we felt comfortable of releasing because
we we have high level of confidence it's
accurate in terms of timeframe and
location and activity particularly of
the principal individual who is
responsible for these mass shootings in
these murders yeah I think there's going
to be some evidence of that the question
was was that play in that night don't
know yet and that's part of the
toxicology report that typically takes
six weeks the corner last late last week
said hope to get it in two weeks so
that's an important piece once again it
gets a mindset won't know that for at
least two weeks there was some evidence
of drug paraphernalia
you know hard to say Mike I can tell you
he was in the Oregon district on Friday
night so what was his mindset then I
don't know he was not unfamiliar with
this area and the fact he was there the
night before you know certainly have to
consider there was some thought being
given to it at that time okay we looked
I mean Paul you folks looked at I don't
think so anybody else in the alleyway
during that time no so there's two
different segments the period that we
really can't see him clearly and that's
one as the when he's at the car with the
branch in the way and then you're
talking about the high Newcomb's yeah
there were people in the alley in the in
the parking lot behind Newcomb's blind
Bob's there were some people back there
there was nobody that went back to the
area where from either side we have
video from the Newcomb side then we have
the video from blind BA or from Hart
mercantile actually so nobody went back
there there were no vehicles that came
into play during that point so he
appears to be back there alone so to
chamber a chamber around basically your
your bullets are in a magazine at some
type when you charge a gun you are
working the action so that one of the
rounds goes up into the chamber to the
gun second fire
well you know just was just informed I
talked to Todd wicker ham Sunday night
because this was on my mind a bit and
had been informed and he gotten in the
phone I don't know there's a lot more
detail we I don't have a high level of
detail what was in there but I don't
have a sense there's anything that's
revealed but particularly revealing at
this time they have to have an
opportunity to go through that and
there's there's other evidence to they
have to go through so nothing that I'm
aware of at this time that emerge of
significance in its initial examination
no I'm not aware of any diagnosis I am
aware that he had undergone some
treatment and I can't comment further on
that but I am aware of that it seems so
it seems so
correct right I don't think he could
have put that weapon in it's fully built
out state in that backpack and not have
it sticking out so in some degree I
think it was just assembled I think
that's a pretty fair conclusion the
dural and of course you had that drawn
magazine too so yeah I think he that's I
think that's part of the explanation for
the 9 minutes
right and that's noticing the fact that
the backpack was a pair to be weighed
down so it's safe to say it was probably
in the backpack and the we've checked
with our lot of our weapons tax and SWAT
guys they all kind of concur that most
likely that weapon had be broken down
there was a question even a visibility
aquaian honestly from that alley because
you have the patio blind bombs you have
all those umbrellas you know kind of
hanging down you her and the companion
are on the opposite side of the tacos
and so there's a real question could
even see who that was on the other side
which is why I'm saying this the
evidence seems to be questionable
although it's very clear 7 minutes
before he started shooting he knew they
were there they've no indication that
they knew
you know that's still I guess it was
conversation in progress
but I think that probably that of
greatest significance that there's not
seem to be any indication that he was
aware as I said before the existence of
the weapons in the trunk or what the
assailant intended to do that night no I
don't think you may have but you know if
that was part of the interview I'm not
aware of the the response you know that
is been I was a beautiful
work-in-progress and at this time I
don't have that level of detail I mean
it was literally to now be able to tell
you today it's not 14 gunshot when
victims at 17 so just trying to get
their identity demographics we need to
get offense reports we need to get
medical records I mean that has a lot
goes into trying to establish what
happened and how they were injured
etcetera so well you know this community
is remarkable just remarkable
I'm amazed at their response just amazed
it's so gracious so grateful so caring
so this is a beautiful community Wow
yeah their response was crucial their
response was immediate
the response was effective the response
was compassionate yeah there's no
indication that there was anything
unlawful and the purchase or acquisition
of those that I know over there at this
time
could be could be part of that is going
back historically and trying to
determine that right and you know was it
occasional drug use or was it daily drug
you I mean there there's a lot of gap to
fill in to kind of make that call no I
well I don't think we got a little
detail I don't think was in possession
or isn't a car but it was on person do
we know there was some found on it was a
car the person so there's evidence
obtained this room knows somebody knows
but I don't know okay
yeah there's paraphernalia there's no
question about as part of the evidence
is being analyzed you know we'll have to
get back I I don't have the level of
detail and nobody in the room seems to
have it either so none of us have it we
probably ask right I think that's it you
guys don't have any other questions
you're good yeah
look I think I think that the victims in
the hospital
appreciated the president the United
States coming I think that the first
responders appreciated it I think it was
difficult on the community because he
has such a everyone has very strong
feelings about the president both
positive and negative and so when we're
talking about bringing the community
together he's not helpful there yeah so
I just met with some folks of the
Business Association we're in the
process of putting together a committee
to discuss this to make sure that we
have a permanent site we want to make
sure that we have a victim advocate
there the Business Association there the
city there and then make that decision
on the site so we feel pretty
comfortable it'll be coming but we're
not moving like super fast at the same
time well there was always the agreement
that we would keep the site up until the
funerals were complete and you know a
lot of the site had a like depth flowers
etc it was it was looking a little rough
and I don't think that's well how we
want to remember victims either so the
the cleaning of that up I think was just
a timely timely part we know that people
are still mourning and grieving so
there's still space there so that's not
what was done but you know we want to
make sure that we honor these victims
and their and their life in an
appropriate way okay thank you guys
Oh chief has one honest person just on
his person how's that have a good one
guys